oh okay c4 and decision time for black
e6e 5d6 g6e 5b six but now we're very
limited after that second move now it's
d5 are here greenfeld land oh I should
have done something else maybe no I'll
go with this I guess I have to remove
pre-move land I'm forgetting um there's
a game played in the tal memorial raja
baath versus Cara wanna raja baath
having the white side rugby one to get
off of this diagonal and put pressure on
this pawn do that right now play like
Roger Bobb i'm also i'm not blindly just
following a GM game but um now what
where is my bishop below was I supposed
to insert a check first or something I
don't know that year Queen here
you want to do candidate moves Queen d2
Knight f3 I'm reluctant to play Queen d2
um Knight f3 I have to watch out for pin
city do I care about being pinned maybe
I do not hear bishop in I'm spending so
much time on things i should know if I
would only pick up a book I don't pick
up books I don't pick up books lazy okay
um it's my thinking sound right there
nine f3 ah can you believe it believe it
none of the above Queen d2 says I'm not
quite sure what I want to do really in
fact no I mean I have some thoughts here
and that is if like the night place to
c6 I could kick it away without the
bishop snipping this pawn although Queen
85 could be a bit annoying I don't know
what I'm doing I need to find I need to
avoid the grim film I need to avoid the
grin felt if you don't know how to play
it shame on you okay what about this
what about this now oh this bishops
gonna bite on a rock now isn't he
rockbiter right here
okay and now I don't have to worry about
scary pins his bishops not coming out
here unless he gets a becomes a night
she starts getting a little jumpy this
Bishop can't move either because I get
this pond should I take this pond what's
the trick we know what the story is with
the clock but what's the trick here the
trick is take this pond the Queen comes
out the pressure on this the partner
here's the here's the situation I'm
faced with right now I'm in a position
where I just don't know what I want to
do so I'm going to finish my development
and as I get more development in only
later I take this and maybe now take it
should take it right now right now cuz
I'm not long off from finishing my
development I'm take it now what's the
trick I could not be fought for a trick
okay let's give it a whirl is that a
poison pond that I just eat some poison
right there I might have I like that
this Bishop can't do too much I want to
maintain this structure being silly here
for a little bit here but on a more
serious note I want to keep these guys
right here I also have to be aware of F
for my bishop is running short on
squares so in other words my queen can
call too far away and now that's a
little bit scary the Knights ready to
move so what does that mean my bishop
will be hit well rook here this is so
scary rook here hitting a couple things
indirectly stopping queen a five in fact
that was my first thought I was like I
don't want the Queen to come to a 5 i'm
down less than two I think there's
chop-chop push takes and a bunch of
captures on this square and then my
Center collapses but oh no that can't be
right can it now there's no more
pressure on d I really want to take this
Bishop and then get a pin or ski or
something let me do this first I could
just work on the B file I might want to
one day just get back to be seven or
even this C 5 square starts to be very
appealing where it's just hitting
everything and it's so appealing I think
I'm going to go there no no no no
there's tricks if I do that let's run
home sort of I want to still be in a
spot to double if I played here I think
there is night takes if I take the rook
there's an in-betweener or maybe there
wouldn't be because I'd be on the bishop
ending how I can't calculate now no time
to calculate I need to get rid of this
guy this right here is the number one
piece for black I'm identifying this guy
is their number one piece and he just
gave himself up why would my opponent do
that I'm on the night I have the bishop
pair this queen is getting excited about
stuff she needs to go I'm also do uh Oh
could I could have just trapped the
Queen haha just play your Bishop here
next time I want any again I think I'm
whining get out of their queen I cannot
deal with you I just want to Queen trade
I think that all assure me a win there's
less to worry about man I should have
just played Bishop g5 trap that Queen
you take three Queens take free Queens
clean here let's trade let's just get
the ladies off and let's go into an
endgame land where
I'm up material if you're up material if
you're tuning in here what's the big
trick what's a good strategy well if you
are up material you should trade like a
maniac trade that made no sense let's go
here let's target this pond he's going
down um yeah let's just go after them
I'll get this one at the end of it 51
tickers trade City Oh Patrick's trying
to get active Patrick's going to get
active let's hit this pond let's get
these guys go on this Bishop still isn't
doing anything great big trouble big
trouble on this diagonal be very scared
my opponent has to be scared now right
the roofs going to give a check first
off double check me watch out for the
double check mate I was just pinned
attack pinned pieces don't capture him
good rule of thumb to look into first
look into attacking before capturing
them okay now plenty of time bishop here
rook here is double check me let's go
here and then push away to Victory Lane
plush push where's the mate this is
plenty of time making two threat
one and discovered checkmate next well
that's not me i should have promoted to
a night just to be sure but doesn't
matter i had auto promote on ok good
game let me go back let's flip the board
and look at how either one of us could
have improved for me I should be going
with something different yeah I
shouldn't have been going with this rook
be one move I think it still is a movie
I just I'm not uh up with the times here
I don't know about the theory and I
think f5 is maybe not right I don't know
I could be way off with this again in
that first game Kings attacker put me
right my place he said no a4 was theory
and I believe you that's just I don't I
don't really don't know so I just have
to go with my general opening knowledge
to a guide my play I'm always thinking
on my own that was a recent comment by
the way on a YouTube video someone
asking me sound like you don't really
know what you're doing there then in not
those kind of words but basically like
questioning my understanding of the
opening tonight responded back saying
now I know very little opening theory so
certainly a weakest weakest phase in my
game so I don't know about f5 though um
what about knight c6 put more pressure
on this guy I think knight c6 it caused
me some problems for example about this
knight c6 d5 and you don't react to the
pawn takes Knight threat instead you
play Queen a five and you converge on
this point does that work
and then maybe there's a follow up with
like rip da and you still don't have to
do anything about this pond threatening
the night and maybe you could even
attack it with e6 I think this is a
variation to look into instead of f5
that's what i'm getting at the night
queen night developing to classical
square works well right this is the idea
put pressure on d for the night doing
just that by going to c6 I don't know if
it's theory it seems logical enough
reasonable enough development tempo
instead of making a committal move like
f5 opening this diagonal allowing me to
shut in the bishop like this with e5
unless you have a direct follow up with
like f for being disruptive to my bishop
and then getting a d4 but I'm not really
seeing that happen so okay that's my
main suggestion excite I think this is a
tough road ahead now I don't have to
worry about pins on my night or pressure
on my night I should say and well
probably shouldn't give up the pond
either but i think i start to stand
better after this f5 wolf okay some
rough thoughts in a brief game right
there five minute or so let me close